et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
ricoquer le bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous député la France
insoumise de la Seine-Saint-Denis
président de la commission des finances
à l'Assemblée nationale en étant sans
pendant 20 minutes prenez une interview
en partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Stéphane Vernet de
westfrance bonjour Stéphane bonjour
bonjour
hier soir sur ce sujet promettant un
retour à la normale dans la semaine qui
vient qu'en pensez-vous vous y croyez
si le gouvernement persiste à être du
côté des raffineurs plutôt que du côté
des salariés qui demandent juste
répartition des bénéfices
pharaoniques accumulées par total and Co
ça va être compliqué parce que là
actuellement
j'allais dire que les salariés ne font
finalement qu'impliquer ce que Bruno Le
Maire madame borne ont demandé depuis
des mois ils se disent ils ont dit il
faudrait que les salaires augmentent
nous demandons que les salaires
augmentent nous sommes sûr que les
groupes qui font des bénéfices
historiques vont finir par augmenter ça
ils l'ont jamais fait c'est ça la
situation actuelle les salariés ne font
que réclamer une part normale des
bénéfices accumulés par total donc
devrait d'ailleurs les appuyer parce que
c'est eux qui sont efficaces il y a eu
un accord majoritaire qui n'a pas été
signé par la CGT donc la CGT continue de
bloquer est-ce que vous trouvez ça
normal que malgré l'accord la CGT
correspondait
pas dire que elle veut pas dire de mode
ça c'est pas on siffle pas la fin du
match comme ça les syndicats et pas
seulement les syndicats les salariés
parce que je peux remarquer que si les
occupations non seulement continuent
même se développe estime que l'accord
qui a été trouvé n'est pas suffisant par
rapport justement à cette répartition
nécessaire des bénéfices de total donc
ils continuent
un accord majoritaire et que les
salariés continuent
si les salariés ne sont pas satisfait ne
se reconnaissent pas dans cet accord que
vous sifflez la fin de la grève là
aujourd'hui c'est pas c'est pas quelques
euros qui doivent être distribués aux
salariés demande 10 % en gros
d'augmentation quand Monsieur le PDG
total par exemple c'est augmenté environ
50 % en un an et quand total ou les
groupes pétroliers font des bénéfices
qui vont encore doubler cette année et
dont ce qui double en plus c'est la
parodistribué aux dividendes donc c'est
insupportable c'est insupportable parce
que nous on le paye au prix de la pompe
nous payons ces bénéfices voilà tous les
faut que les les usagers les les
personnes qui aujourd'hui essaient de
trouver de l'essence le sachent et les
salariés le paie parce que c'est sur
leur salaire que ce que aussi ces
bénéfices et comment alors comment
comment on peut siffler la fin de la
greffe pour reprendre la le terme que
vous avez utilisé il faudrait que le
gouvernement mette une grosse pression
sur total pour les obliger à céder sur
les revendications au lieu d'appeler au
réquisition faudrait que le gouvernement
aille jusqu'au bout de la logique
puisque ils disent même jusqu'au bout
c'est dire c'est des donner les 10%
d'augmentation côté 10%, c'est rien par
rapport à deux fois plus de bénéfices et
dividendes parce que là c'est pas c'est
pas une augmentation de de 10% c'est des
augmentations du double qui qui à la fin
produisent par exemple pour total des
bénéfices qui vont certainement être
environ de 20 milliards cette année
enfin c'est au gouvernement c'est au
président de la République de smellsa de
se mêler de négociation salariale
des salariés donc il s'emmêle mais ils
s'en mêle du côté de Total et des
raffineurs donc il faudrait peut-être
qu'il s'en mêle du côté des salariés et
ça serait plus efficace parce que je
remarque une chose c'est que si on parle
de tout ça c'est parce qu'ils se sont
mis en grève et qu'ils ont occupé les
raffiner sinon on en parlerait pas sinon
il y aurait pas d'augmentation de
salaire à l'horizon donc on en parle
parce qu'ils ont fait ça voilà donc
c'est eux qui sont efficaces si le
gouvernement est FID et j'allais dire en
phase avec ce qu'il disait il y a
quelques mois comme quoi il faut
augmenter les salaires j'ai pas arrêté
de les entendre dire ça et bien ils
doivent j'allais dire donner le le le
enfin nous c'est ce qu'on ferait en tout
cas voilà on s'adressait à total on
s'adresserait
aura fini alors on dirait bon bah nous
nous soutenons ces salariés ils ont
raison il faut que vous vous saisiez à
leur revendication voilà et je pense que
c'est c'est malheureusement à mon avis
c'est pas la logique qui sont en train
de prendre mais je vais vous dire des
choses je pense qu'ils vont gagner les
salariés d'abord parce que il y a des
appels maintenant à la grève générale
interpré par la grève interprétienne de
la pharmacie depuis depuis que Madame
borne a appelé à la réquisition il y a
de plus en plus de raffinerie occupé
Force Ouvrière vient de rejoindre la CGT
donc c'est plutôt en train de s'élargir
et prendre et j'ai vu quand même que
malgré tout le battage fait par le
gouvernement aujourd'hui plus de la
moitié des personnes interrogées c'est
42% s'il est bien compris soutiennent ce
mouvement alors même qu'on leur explique
sans arrêt que il subisse ce que ce que
font les griffes bah ils ont compris la
plupart des Français ont compris que
quand ils payent le prix du carburant
plus cher et quand les salariés ne sont
pas suffisamment payés c'est la même
cause bon et Bruno Le Maire à l'instant
sur RTL dit il est évident total
d'augmenter ses salaires c'est un bon
message délivré parmi les autres
messages qu'il faut employer mais je
crains que dans la même dans le même
temps Bruno Le Maire explique aussi
qu'il faille que la grève les
occupations s'arrêtent donc c'est ça qui
est paradoxal dans le discours du
gouvernement vous vous souvenez l'appel
à la crève générale on est d'accord
qu'est-ce que vous dites juste Éric
Coquerel aux Français qui font la queue
pendant des heures pour faire de
l'essence avec parfois des bagarres
aussi maintenant aux stations essence à
ceux qui ne peuvent pas travailler
je le vois bien à ceux qui ne peuvent
plus aller travailler faute de carburant
aux écoliers qui n'ont plus de transport
scolaire qu'est-ce que vous leur dites
ce matin je dis que c'est les mêmes
responsables contre lesquels se
mobilisent aujourd'hui les salariés des
raffineries et qui et qui aujourd'hui
font en sorte que leur vie soit plus
difficile on sait très bien d'où vient
l'augmentation de faire des d'où vient
l'augmentation du carburant au départ le
rotation du carburant elle vient à la
fois de la spéculation des pays
producteurs et des marges bénéficiaires
fait par des raffineurs et tous ceux qui
distributeurs et autres voilà c'est
c'est de ça donc ça vient parce que je
vous ferai marquer que tout ça n'y a pas
après une période où les prix du
carburants étaient n'ont pas flambés au
contraire ils ont flambé donc maintenant
dans cette situation là ce n'est pas
normal et les Français d'ailleurs c'est
bien pour ça que vous allez voir on en
parlera tout à l'heure dans ce projet de
loi de finance il va y avoir des taxes
sur les super profits qui vont passer
les Français je crois comprennent très
bien que certes il subit cette situation
mais c'est la faute des mêmes
c'est-à-dire ceux qui j'allais dire
spéculent sur le prix du carburant et
exploite en plus leur salarié voilà
c'est ça fait beaucoup de choses quand
même
en même temps il y a comment depuis le
depuis le début enfin depuis un petit
moment vous avez total qui ajoute une
ristourne supplémentaire de 20 centimes
par rapport à l'aide d'Etat est-ce que
ça c'est c'est pas aussi quelque chose
qui a augmenté le les difficultés et
puis à l'arrivée si total à force de
rajouter ces aides supplémentaires et
augmente effectivement ces salariés
qu'est-ce qui va rester pour gentil pour
eux vous inquiétez pas
c'est 500 millions d'euros c'est pas du
tout les mêmes échelles
par rapport à des dizaines 500 millions
d'euros c'est quoi c'est les 20 centimes
supplémentaires mais
mission flash vous savez qui a été faite
par ma commission sur les super profits
des entreprises pétrolières et le PDG
des saut est venu témoigner en disant ça
a été un excellent coup de communication
pour total et une affaire parce que au
final les gens sont venus chez Total et
ils ont encore plus je veux dire ils ont
fait en sorte que les chiffres
d'affaires de Total les bénéfices de
Total augmente donc bon voilà je je le
gouvernement a présenté ça comme un
effort de Total je pensais à coup de com
c'est une bonne affaire pour eux et ça
n'équivaut pas à ce qui est nécessaire
c'est-à-dire l'anesté d'aller taxer les
super profonds leur image leur image un
peu évolué dans l'autre sens là depuis
depuis les blocages
les raisons le spectacle qui est donné
ou le le résultat est quand même pas
super positif non non ça je pense c'est
pas positif mais quand le PDG total va
je l'ai dit tout à l'heure mais enfin
quand même se rendre compte que le PDG
de Total gagne 6 millions d'euros
presque 6 millions d'euros par an il
s'est augmenté de 52%. comment vous
pouvez justifier à partir de là que vous
n'augmentez pas vos salariés de 10%
enfin c'est quelque chose
d'insupportable comment vous pouvez je
termine comment vous pouvez justifier
dans le même moment que l'État ne doit
pas prendre c'est-à-dire l'intérêt
général une partie de vos super profits
pour servir par exemple la transition
écologique ou à la justice sociale et
justement on va en parler puisque le
gouvernement a finalement inscrit dans
le projet de loi de finance la
contribution exceptionnelle de
solidarité pour les entreprises de
l'énergie qui réalise des bénéfices
exceptionnels ça c'est une bonne chose
vous la voterez ah c'est un premier pas
positif mais il a fallu pousser je vous
rappelle parce que là encore Bruno Le
Maire il y a quelques temps de ça
c'était en juillet je me rappelle design
il n'y aura pas nous n'augmenterons pas
les impôts donc les y compris sur les
super profits donc ils ont fini par y
aller pourquoi d'abord parce que tous
les pays européens finissent par y aller
même le effet humide leur commande et
puis il y a des opposition comme nous la
nupesse qui poussons à cela donc ils ont
fini par fumer ça mais là c'est un
premier pas mais qui coûte pas grand
chose c'est 200 millions d'euros que ça
va à peu près rapporter pourquoi parce
que notamment une entreprise comme Total
figurez-vous fait l'exploit de ne payer
0 impôt sur les société en France alors
qu'elle fait des milliards de bénéfices
donc il faut quelque chose de
complémentaire par rapport à cette
mesure qu'on veut trah mais quelque
chose de complémentaire et ça a commencé
hier parce que notamment sur proposition
du modèle vous voyez ça s'élargit a été
voté un premier abonnement qui taxe des
dividendes c'est pas les surpris mais
les survivants je pense que c'est bien
ciblé mais d'avoir d'autres et je pense
que le gouvernement ne pourra pas
longtemps résister à protéger les super
profits brasser des amendement du MoDem
qui a été voté avec la porte de voie de
renaissance aussi il y a une vingtaine
de sûreté Renaissance ça vous a surpris
pas vraiment parce que si vous regardez
bien ce sont les mêmes députés de
renaissance qui avait proposé une un
amendement sur les super profits lors du
projet de loi de finances rectificative
horizon c'est abstenu aussi ce qui
montre bien une chose c'est que ce
gouvernement il est de plus en plus
minoritaire et que manifestement la
menace du 49-3 elle est pas seulement
par rapport à ses oppositions elle
devient même par rapport à une partie
entre guillemets on peut même plus
parler majorité on va dire de minorité
qu'il soutient donc voilà c'est ça que
ça révèle c'est que ce gouvernement ce
propose sur le met sur la table et de
plus en plus minoritaire à l'Assemblée
parce qu'en réalité c'est de plus en
plus minoritaire dans le pays justement
on va parler du 49-3 Stéphane puisque
sans grande surprise Olivier Veyron a
annoncé que le Conseil des ministres
avaient délibéré là-dessus oui alors le
ça veut dire que il y aura probablement
ou très probablement un recours au 49-3
la question c'est à quel moment à votre
avis quand est-ce que le gouvernement va
dégainer le 49-3 on a reposé la question
à Bruno Le Maire qui était à côté de moi
sur le bon de l'assemblée il a dit qu'on
va laisser faire le débat au train pas
aujourd'hui on craint pas demain bon
comme il a pas il a pas été plus loin je
pense qu'on peut le craindre au début de
la semaine prochaine moi je continue à
dire au début de semaine prochaine vous
pensez lundi et mardi bah oui le débat
s'arrête mercredi donc il utilise avant
moi je continue à dire au gouvernement
qu'il ne doit pas utiliser le 49-3 je
sais qu'il a le droit
institutionnellement mais politiquement
ça serait non seulement une faute c'est
une faute démocratique mais en plus
c'est une erreur pour lui voilà il
devrait enfin admettre une chose c'est
qu'il n'a pas de majorité à l'Assemblée
c'est ça qu'ils ont dû c'est ça qui va
parler du fond mais hier Olivier Véran
vous l'avez sans doute entendu la sortie
du Conseil des ministres il dit on
utilisera que en cas de situation
blocage ou de posture de l'opposition de
quoi de posture de l'opposition c'est le
fait que l'opposition s'oppose
excusez-moi mais on est en démocratie
quand même il y a pas de blocage je le
dis pour que les choses soient claires
regardez les débats la façon il se passe
c'est des argumentés il y a un nombre
d'amendements raisonnable c'est pas
c'est pas 3500
une méthode où il décline chaque
amendement quasiment par chaque député
il a plein qui sont abandonnés donc nous
franchement il y a pas de blocage de ce
type voilà il y a des argumentés en fait
ce que le gouvernement pourquoi il met
le 49-3 c'est parce que c'est une façon
de dire je peux perdre amendement par
amendement et vous allez voir qu'il va
en perdre encore beaucoup aujourd'hui
mais à la fin je vais je vais rétablir
mon budget c'est une espèce d'assurance
j'allais dire
comment comment est-ce qu'ils peuvent
comment est-ce que le gouvernement peut
rétablir le son budget à la fin s'il
perd beaucoup d'amendement il peut le
décider il peut décider les deux il peut
décider en lui pose la question depuis
hier d'ailleurs je j'en profite je
repose la question aujourd'hui je pose
la question à Bruno Le Maire je vais
voir tout à l'heure on a une réponse
l'ordi est-ce que si vous faites le 49-3
est-ce que vous allez garder les
amendements qui sont aujourd'hui Majorie
et l'argent majoritaire il ne répond pas
je crains qu'il ne le fasse pas pourquoi
berger sur notre antenne elle a dit oui
elle a dit ça nous empêchera pas de
garder des amendements voir des
amendements qui n'ont pas été débattus
lesquels il faudrait pas entendu
exécuter dire oui bah moi je pense qu'il
serait normal que tous les amendements
qui ont été majoritaires soient
conservés c'est la souveraineté de
l'assemblée il y a quelques-uns par
exemple
des dividendes il faut le garder par
exemple hier vous avez rejeté quand je
dis vous c'est les oppositions les
députés ont rejeté l'article qui
contient l'objectif de contenir le
déficit public à 5% en 2020
est-ce que vous comprenez que le
gouvernement dise c'est quand même pour
eux
compliqué de voter un budget où il n'y a
pas de problème s'il voulait chercher
peut-être pas une majorité mais au moins
par exemple une abstention parmi une de
ces oppositions on sait que on s'oppose
pas pour les mêmes raisons en gros les
républicains disent ça dépend trop et
nous on dit il y a pas assez
d'investissement il y a trop de cadeaux
aux entreprises sans contrepartie etc
donc on dit pas tout à fait la même
chose mais il pourrait au moins se dire
de qui il se sent le plus proche de qui
sont le programme son budget se sent
plus proche et à partir de là faire les
changements nécessaires pas des
changements j'allais dire homéopathique
qui l'ont plus qu'il fait de manière
contrainte il pourrait anticiper je ne
suis pas majoritaire donc à partir de là
comment je vais chercher si c'était une
majorité au moins une abstention il ne
le fait pas il reste il y a eu les
dialogues de Bercy
bah écoutez là je le constate
c'est-à-dire que y compris l'amendement
hier il a il a il a été obligé de
l'adopter il a pas proposé lui-même il
nous avait dit je vous donne un exemple
ils nous disent au dialogue de Bercy
il y a trop de niche fiscales c'est vrai
que c'est insupportable vous avez raison
d'où on le dénonce depuis longtemps il y
a une niche fiscale qui servent à rien
en plus si on peut le ok on arrive au
niveau de la propulsion lourd on a un
article qui propose 6 minuscules niches
fiscales qui servent quasiment plus à
rien disparu et rien d'autre alors on
dit par exemple le crédit pour recherche
qui coûte même 6 milliards on pourrait
le réformer ok on le supprime pas si
vous voulez mais on le réforme par
exemple les entreprises qui touchent de
de du crédit approchage tout en
licenciant des chercheurs c'est quand
même un normal c'est fait pour la
recherche bah faites quelque chose il ne
bouge pas de iota en réalité ils sont
toujours partis sur l'idée comme comme
lorsqu'ils étaient largement
majoritaires qu'ils ont un projet que ce
projet doit peu bouger et bah non il se
trompe s'ils veulent tenir dans le temps
s'ils veulent faire en sorte que de
continuer à gouverner ce pays ils
doivent remodeler profondément leur
budget pas de manière homéopathique et
c'est pas ce qu'ils veulent faire donc
ils vont dans le mur parce que même si
j'utilise le 49-3 ce n'est que reculer
pour mieux sauter parce qu'à un moment
donné la réalité des prix ça va finir
par s'afficher et vous verrez que ils
seront de plus en plus dans une
difficulté donc même ce matin vous leur
dites alors que vivent annoncé que le
Conseil des ministres avait délibéré
vous leur dites renoncé
avec le presque pour leur intérêt parce
que sinon le 49-3 n'annonce c'est
un faux coup de c'est un coup de force
mais qui est un aveu de faiblesse voilà
un mot là-dessus parce qu'il y a un
sujet qui aide beaucoup les élus locaux
et les collectivités c'est la Hauser
prix de l'énergie est-ce que pour vous
il faut aller jusqu'à indexer la
dotation globale de fonctionnement
jusqu'à l'inflation
et puis il faut abandonner alors ils
sont minorités vous pouvez nous
expliquer pourquoi parce que on s'attend
à avoir une très grosse inflation
l'année prochaine parce que ce sera deux
chiffres parce que les collectivités
locales qui ont fait beaucoup d'efforts
pendant des années sur la question
justement de maintenir les budgets ils
sont de façon obligé de le faire donc
ils ont ils ont fait l'effort ne peuvent
pas pâtir de la situation et si le
pâtissier de la situation ce serait les
citoyens parce qu'il redistribue
beaucoup à travers des investissements
etc or le problème c'est que si ça suit
pas l'inflation ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que ce sont les
investissements à terme qui seront
touchés et avec des conséquences fortes
le font le fond vert par exemple que le
gouvernement vend faut bien comprendre
le chaud le fond vert vraiment dit je
mets un milliard 5 sur la table pour au
nom de l'écologie pour les collectivités
mais il ne peut s'activer que si les
collectivités ont de l'argent au départ
pour et pour
initier ce fond vert si elle n'en ont
pas il y aura pas de fond vert et
malheureusement je crois que ce qui est
prévu aujourd'hui en matière budgétaire
va les empêcher d'investir donc c'est
une faute une faute de plus il y a aussi
un débat sur la CVE la cotisation avale
rajoutée des entreprises que le
gouvernement veut supprimer à horizon 2
ans le en disant ça sera dédommagé il y
a une fraction de la TVA pour vous c'est
acceptable ce mécanique
là ça touche le fond du problème le
gouvernement nous dit
continuent à s'appuyer sur des chiffres
qui n'ont pas de de réalité il dit on
aura quand même 1% de croissance l'an
prochain qui importe que toutes les
institutions internationales vous n'y
croyez pas non mais non mais non et en
plus je vais vous dire pourquoi je pense
que j'ai raison c'est que cet été au
moment du programme de stabilité le
gouvernement tablet sur un 5 moi je leur
ai dit pas que moi il y a le Haut
Conseil des finances publiques vous vous
trompez ça sera beaucoup plus faible il
a été obligé de commencer à rectifier en
disant il y aura un pour cent de
croissance bon et maintenant les
institutions sociales disent s'il y a 04
vous avez de la chance et c'est plutôt
la récession mais ça ça a des
conséquences fortes parce que si c'est
la récession et que vous baissez les
dépenses publiques
à un moment donné vous allez augmenter
la récession n'importe quel économiste
le sait et en baissant les impôts la CBA
il perd 4 milliards d'euros
d'investissement 4 milliards pour les
dépenses publiques donc c'est ce budget
d'un point de vue macroéconomique est
une erreur
sur les retraites Elisabeth borne reçoit
les présidents de groupe parlementaires
aujourd'hui quel message et quel
compromis vont être vous prêt à faire
sur les retraites c'est très simple il
est pas question que l'âge de la
retraite
recule ni que les cotisations le
restaurant ou pas voilà c'est les bases
c'est ce qu'ils veulent fixer comme base
on pense que on pense que c'est ni le
moment alors là vraiment pas le moment
dans la période qui va arriver de
récession et de risque de crise
économique et en plus c'est une erreur
bon ils veulent le mettre vous nous
permettrez de penser que on doit pas
toucher à ça donc
c'est pas un problème
a priori et j'ai cru comprendre
d'ailleurs je suis un peu inquiet parce
que j'ai vu qu'Emmanuel Macron avait
quasiment convoqué par la presse non
seulement les responsables de des
groupes majoritaires majoritaires de
plus en plus entre guillemets mais aussi
les parties d'opposition pour le voir je
sais pas et pour discuter des retraites
et du projet de loi de finance de la
sécurité sociale j'espère qu'il n'a pas
l'idée de réintroduire cette question
voilà je le pose aujourd'hui parce que
j'ai vu que les deux étaient liés on va
attendre ce qui se passe j'espère
franchement j'espère parce que là ça
serait une déclaration de guerre au
monde du salariat et là encore je pense
qu'il irait dans un mur tout comme
d'ailleurs à mon avis il allait en
janvier moi je crois que sur les
retraites ça passera pas je vais vous la
fermera aussi par un top 3 oui mais 49-3
ça va se terminer par une notion de
censure il le sait et ça va se terminer
par le fait que la mobilisation sociale
dans le pays je peux vous assurer qu'à
mon avis là si j'ai une certitude c'est
que il va y avoir une mobilisation très
forte sur la question des retrait de
mobilisation peut-être mais la motion de
censure les républicains la voteront pas
sur les retraites on verra bien on verra
bien que c'est possible on verra bien
ils disent que la méthode ne va pas
d'accord et la motion bon moi j'entends
ce qu'il disait même mettons mettons ça
de côté moi je crois que le mouvement
social la mobilisation sociale fera
échec à ce à un projet comme elle a fait
échec au projet de la réforme par point
tout simplement parce que au moment où
il faudrait redistribuer une part de la
valeur ajoutée dans les salaires ça
revient la discussion qu'on a eu au
départ c'est pas le moment de forcer les
gens à travailler plus longtemps
toujours a priori au bénéfice justement
de dimanche servira de tests
il y aura beaucoup de monde
en plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
personnes après moi je suis pas ça sera
un succès et je le sais parce que ça ça
remonte de plus en plus et puis en plus
c'est sur la question de la vie chère
sur la question de la bifurcation
écologique sur la question des retraites
autant de thèmes sur lesquels les
salariés commencent à mobiliser donc je
pense qu'ils peuvent sans parler de
cette marche pour en faire un grand
succès et puis on aura d'autres par la
suite vous le verrez mais le 16 octobre
14h à Nation vous verrez que la nupesse
des syndicalistes des associations
j'allais dire vont vont un peu augmenter
le rapport de force vis-à-vis du
gouvernement et le message est passé un
dernier mot sur votre partie Éric
Coquerel et
Mélenchon qui a réaffirmé à nouveau son
soutien Adrien katnens dimanche avec une
phrase qui a fait réagir puisqu'il a
parlé de gifle médiatique qui était
donné à Adrien katnas ce matin midi et
soir Marlène Schiappa qui était à votre
place en début de semaine a dit qu'avec
Jean-Luc Mélenchon la France insoumise
s'enfoncée dans l'anti féminisme
qu'est-ce que vous dites
je pense que elle ferait mieux de
regarder du côté de son camp et en
général pour plein de raisons ne
serait-ce que parce que dans ces cas-là
c'est la seule chose qu'on retient de de
ce type d'entretien je fais pas de
commentaires sur tout ça
quiconque j'allais dire vis-à-vis du
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et de de tout ce
qu'il a mis sur la table sur la question
égalité homme-femme depuis maintenant
des mois qui compte peut je veux dire
l'attaquer là dessus
bon je trouve que c'est mon permis de
dire que c'est un peu politicien et
c'est un peu une façon là encore de
d'affaiblir ce que nous sommes et la
menace que nous représentons pour le
gouvernement moi je crois que vous savez
il y a une chose c'est que dans le
projet de loi de finance il y a un milli
nous proposons un amendement un milliard
plus d'un milliard ont pris le le
revendications des associations pour
lutter contre notamment les féminicides
voilà si des gens veulent montrer que
ils sont au niveau notamment la majorité
notamment même s'il y a pas et bien
qu'ils appellent leurs collègues à votre
testament
interne chez vous parce que François
Ruffin il a l'air
il doit être stratégie il dit qu'il en a
marre de s'égosiller dans l'hémicycle et
il dit ça sert à rien ça renforce le
rassemblement national
on est François Ruffin nous dit que ne
traduit que ce qu'on dit tous
c'est-à-dire qu'à un moment donné il
faut savoir adopter sur la forme notre
tactique par rapport à nos objectifs par
exemple sur le budget et on est
plusieurs à l'avoir recommandé c'est
exactement ce qui se passe on a intérêt
au débat argumenté pour gagner le
maximum d'amendement possible sans
j'allais dire du tout affaiblir la
radicalité de ce que nous proposons mais
c'est ce qui se passe François Ruffin il
le dit lui-même il dit je m'adresse
plutôt à moi ce genre de recommandation
parce que c'est vrai que c'est un de
ceux qui est le général les plus dans
l'hémicycle donc très bien il se
l'adresse à lui mais c'est un avis
global il y a pas de débat là-dessus on
est tous d'accord et puis vous verrez
que si par exemple le gouvernement avait
l'idée saugrenu quand même de présenter
un projet de retraite je pense que
disons ça serait plus frontal vous savez
aujourd'hui dans l'émission
la construction parce que ma petite
panique on pourra déposer je ferai 75
ans pour le coup ça sera frontal pour
faire en sorte que ce projet passe pas
ou l'assume et là sur le budget c'est un
autre thème parce qu'on peut gagner
beaucoup de choses et donc nous sommes
dans le débargumenté ainsi que
aujourd'hui c'est pour faire les malins
sur Twitter en réalité les travaux les
travaux les travaux en commission ce que
vous présidez par exemple sont beaucoup
plus constructifs argumentés et beaucoup
plus apaisés on s'est vu à quelques
jours donc c'est ce que je vous ai
expliqué mais là si vous regardez bien
les débats dans l'hémicycle sont aussi
depuis
du côté de la majorité où il y a des
coups de chaud parce qu'ils ont un peu
du mal à comprendre qu'ils sont
minoritaires et à l'admettre donc depuis
hier ils sont un peuvement mais bon je
pense qu'ils vont se calmer ils finir
par l'admettre
merci d'avoir été notre invité la Une de
Ouest-France et l'agriculture et le défi
des jeunes générations c'est Halloween
de votre journal Stéphane merci
ericoquerelle on passe au club des
territoires
[Musique]